good morning John earlier this week I
was listening to some oldies and I was
like these are all these but how old is
the oldest song on a scale of things
really all these are Dewey's they're
very new where this is an impossible
question to answer the oldest song was
probably sung by a bird maybe a dinosaur
you don't know but I don't think anybody
else has got the music in their soul and
music in the Mickey wouldn't movement on
that oh it's just us and it is innate
like there are no cultures on earth that
do not sing all humans sing that well
all cultures sing there are some humans
particularly ones named John Green who
probably should maybe just not
definitely the first human songs are
well and truly lost they were probably
improvised so the first melody
was probably lost immediately after it
was created the oldest song that we can
still play today is called hurry in hymn
number 6 it's incomplete but it was
pressed into keenya form tablets 3,500
years ago and you can still listen to it
there's clips of it on YouTube that's
amazing archaeologists can let us get a
glimpse at what the past looked like the
buildings and the tools people used in
their pots in their weapons but being
able to hear back in time for some
reason that makes these people who
existed distantly in the past much more
real to me and like much more human to
me however the oldest song that we have
in its entirety is a brief composition
the coolest thing about it is not only
is it music it is also the lyrics which
is really unusual
it's on a burial cylinder probably
placed into the grave of a man's wife by
the man it was not originally played
with an acoustic guitar accompaniment
but that is how I'm gonna play it cuz I
don't have a liar nor do I know how to
play one who songs is
Oh made an all of sealable rosso league
honesty to Zen
- Taillow south on us a pig
Oh songs is vehicle made and all of
sealy paul rosolie godness tito's and
don't tell us honest ability while you
will shine rejoice and dads and seized
our day we're only here until you're
gone and time time demands to be big
metal of sidi bou Oprah solely gone as
deep tours and Joe Joe Sarno sub
the oldest song we have and the theme is
basically Yolo
the more things change I have some news
in this cup of musical history the first
album of Hank green and the perfect
strangers which is called incongruent is
not going to be significant it is
however going to come out at the end of
April or beginning of May
and I'm very excited about it it rocks I
think we were talked about how great my
album is but you will hear more of it
there's already some of it on my tumblr
if you want to check that out there's a
song called I love signs and it is
available to pre-order at dftba.com John
I will see it does it mean any